in the past couple of weeks iPads have
changed a lot there's been the release
of the 20/20 iPad pro which we've
recently reviewed some major changes to
iPad OS and a new line of keyboard cases
now you guys already know that I'm a
huge fan of the iPad pro and I think
it's worth the extra price compared to
the iPad air 3 especially if you're
thinking about the future but I've
realized that you can actually have a
better experience with the iPad air than
the iPad pro if you buy the wrong
keyboard case for the pro I believe that
your iPad experience in 2020 and Beyond
is actually going to be defined by which
keyboard case you have more so than
which iPad you have what I mean is that
you don't want to end up buying the
wrong keyboard case and then being stuck
with it unless you spend another good
amount of cash on the correct keyboard
case so a couple of months back we made
a video comparing the best iPad keyboard
cases available and we ultimately chose
the bridge' pro keyboard as the winner
but now things have very quickly changed
thanks to the most important software
feature being added to the iPad for the
very first time and that's cursor and
trackpad support we tested this out by
connecting apple's magic mouse to which
instantly gave us the freedom to use our
iPad pro touch free this gave us a
massive advantage of quick control for
things like right-click support instead
of having a tap and hold on something
instant drag-and-drop support just like
you get on a Mac and most importantly
accurate cursor control for things like
editing photos and selecting texts we
did a full guide on how to customize and
use cursor support which you can watch
by clicking the end screen button at the
end of this video but the biggest deal
concerning cursor support is that there
is a completely new line of keyboard
cases that are coming soon
which include built-in track pads and
these track pads will automatically
support the cursor so it'll work
basically just like on a MacBook with
all of the same gesture support now
alongside these cases are also ones
without track pads so there are some
people who will buy these being unaware
that there are trackpad cases coming
soon that'll be much more useful for
their needs so in this video I'm going
to break down the most popular keyboard
cases into three different categories
ones without track pads one with track
pad
and once created by Apple the keyboard
cases without trackpads are generally
going to be much cheaper than the others
this includes cases like the bridge pro
case for the iPad pro that we've been
using a bunch and we personally love is
currently on sale for $100 on Amazon
which is a pretty great deal and Bridge
also has similar models available for
the other iPads as well like for the
budget 10.2 inch iPad and iPad air for a
hundred and thirty dollars on Amazon
there's also Logitech which provides the
slim folio pro case for the iPad pro
which is quite a bit more rugged and
drop resistant currently on sale for $96
for the iPad pro but do keep in mind
that since this case protects the back
you need to make sure the camera bump
fits your iPad pro model because the
2020 iPad pro square bump is quite a bit
larger than on the 2018 model and of
course Logitech has basically the same
options for the iPad in the iPad air for
around $100 now what might surprise you
is that Logitech has a keyboard case
with the built-in trackpad for 50
dollars more that adds a ton of
functionality with the cursor support
spending that extra $50 will make a
world of a difference for a lot of
people because it basically turned your
iPad into a laptop Bridge also has their
own Pro Plus keyboard coming in just
about a week which also packs a trackpad
but it's only for the iPad pro being
priced at 230 dollars but because of the
aluminum design and the fully adjustable
hinge is more like a laptop than the
logitech option and then there's the
final category keyboard cases made by
Apple and we're also splitting them into
two categories with and without track
paths for the cases without the 10.2
inch iPad in the iPad air get the smart
keyboard which costs a hundred and fifty
nine dollars and the iPad pro gets the
smart Keyboard folio for a hundred and
seventy nine dollars and interestingly
Apple is making a keyboard case with a
trackpad only for the iPad pro and not
for the other iPads and this one in my
opinion is the ultimate keyboard case
I'll explain why in just a minute so now
let's get into which keyboard case you
should buy for each different use case
if you don't really care about
using your iPad like a laptop with
cursive support then you're better off
getting a case without a trackpad since
you'll save quite a bit of cash if
you're in that boat then I'd recommend
going for the logitech slim folio case
since it's got a high-quality rugged and
protective build it has a built in Apple
pencil holder and it's the least
expensive out of the bunch but if you
could see yourself enjoying cursus
support I would 100% recommend spending
the extra cash on one of the logitech
slim combo cases with a built-in
trackpad for either the 10.2 inch iPad
or the iPad air unfortunately Logitech
doesn't have one of these for the iPad
pro chest yet so if you're an iPad pro
user you're left with the choice of
either the bridge Pro Plus for $230 or
apples magic keyboard case for $300 now
I know that's a lot of money for a case
but I'm fully confident that it's gonna
be so good that it'll take the iPad pro
to a whole new level
and there will be people who will regret
choosing a cheaper case instead there's
a few features of the magic keyboard
case that you literally cannot get
anywhere else and this is what makes it
worth it first off is the only trackpad
keyboard case that's made by Apple that
means you're getting very high build
quality and Apple is known for making
the best trackpads
out there there are already reviews of
the bridge pro plus keyboard case that
complain about the trackpad not really
being that great with scrolling speed
being inconsistent and some gestures not
working like they're supposed to so if
you want to get the best trackpad
experience you want the magic keyboard
case and unlike the Pro Plus which uses
Bluetooth to connect the magic case uses
the physical smart connector on the back
of the iPad pro which means it'll never
lose its connection and it doesn't have
a battery built-in which means you never
have to charge it unlike you have to do
with the Pro Plus in a big benefit is
that the lack of a battery and the
magnetized design makes it much slimmer
so it weighs less and is more portable
one of the best and most unique things
about the probe plus is the fully
adjustable hinge but the magic keyboard
case 1ups it by having a totally unique
floating ipad design
which places your iPad pro closer to you
and the hinge is adjustable as well and
then there's the fact that it gets the
same scissor switch keyboard as the 16
inch MacBook Pro so you're getting a
real laptop keyboard unlike Apple smart
keyboard folio which has these pretty
weird feeling keys and the ones on the
bridge pro which feel a bit mushy
another bonus is that it features
backlighting all through the physical
smart connector which also gives you one
feature you can't get on any other
keyboard case and that's passed through
charging the magic keyboard case has a
USB C port built into the side of the
hinge which routes your charging power
through the smart connector to charge up
your iPad pro and this is awesome
because it leaves your main USB C port
free to connect external drives and
devices the only other way to achieve
this is by attaching an expensive USB C
hub that has passed through charging and
extra ports which some people don't want
to deal with so for those reasons I
fully recommend pre-ordering the magic
keyboard case which should be coming out
next month instead of the Bridge Pro
Plus the only reason I would get the Pro
Plus is if you don't want to spend a
dime over 230 dollars for a case or if
you can find it for under $200 if it
goes on sale I do agree that $300 is
still very expensive but if you choose a
third-party case and you start having
various reliability issues like with the
trackpad not working correctly bluetooth
losing its connection and the battery
dying you might start to wish you just
went straight for the magic keyboard
instead so hopefully this video helps
you guys decide which keyboard case you
should buy for your iPad and if it did
we'll have some links down below for
each of these options thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]